I'm Dave I run a surfboard repair shop  in La and today I'm going to run you  through how to restore a vintage Dewey  rubber surfboard  to start I cleaned the board using a  razor blade and acetone  is pretty easy I'll kind of knock on the  board if it sounds like you're hitting a  countertop that's usually a good sound  if it sounds kind of like a dull Thunder  like cardboard that's the sure side that  it's still illuminated  next I'll check the board for dings  dings are any crap in the fiberglass of  the surfboard fourth step filling these  things that are dented all the way into  the foam of the surfboard  buildings I use Q cell and laminating  them mixing up resin and Q cell when it  cures it forms a chemical bond between  that flap of fiberglass and the foam  core of the surfboard